hi everyone
Sal Khan here welcome to our daily
homeroom livestream as I always explain
this is a way for us to stay together
connected in this time of school
closures Khan Academy we're
not-for-profit with a mission of
providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere and we could have
never foreseen the situation that we're
now finding ourselves in but over the
last roughly decade we've been building
resources that we think can really help
you as a student a parent a teacher keep
students learning over this very
unfortunate situation we are going
through I will remind everyone before we
get into the meat of today's session we
are not-for-profit we exist because of
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself we were running at a deficit
even before this whole kovat crisis it
and now our traffic is almost three
times what it typically is I do want to
give a special thank you for all of you
who've donated over the last several
weeks and especially several of these
corporations you see here
Bank of America really stepped up that
first weekend when they saw that we had
that need Google org AT&T Novartis this
is helping a lot but we need more help
we are continuing to run at an
increasing deficit I also want to give a
special thanks to my wife oh mama this
is my first kovat haircut I got over the
weekend in our backyard I think she's
got some skills too but you know
obviously I'm biased so today or gonna
have a fun session I'm gonna bring on
two of my team members Megan and Jeremy
who are former teachers who've been
leading the webinars that we keep
talking about over on these live streams
and what the collectively what we're
going to do on Friday we had a fun ask
me anything where people are asking
literally anything and now I'm joined by
Megan and Jeremy and you can ask us
anything
and obviously Megan and Jeremy are
expert at how does Khan Academy work in
a classroom they're the ones running the
webinars and they can talk more about
some of the webinars are about to run
common questions they've seen but also
ask us anything about anything
so Megan Jeremy thanks for joining us
may be a good place to start I know
Megan I'll start with you tell us a
little bit about these
rzl are running and what what types of
things you're trying to get across sure
thanks al
we are running webinars for teachers who
are transitioning from being in the
classroom every day with their students
to teaching and learning remotely and
where you've covered everything from how
to set up your Khan Academy account to
best practices to even having teachers
who are you know are really exceptional
ambassadors who are sharing their best
practices for different students in
different areas so it could be math
could be English language learners could
be science and so we're having both our
teams share some of the things that we
know work really well along with
teachers around the country sharing
their best ideas to really form a
community of teaching and learning
remotely and we have two webinars coming
up this week one for best practices for
supporting students who are special
education and one for best practices for
supporting English language learners and
those are on Wednesday and Friday
respectively that's super useful and
Jeremy what would you say that you are
Megan you and Megan are seeing as some
of the the main I guess pain points that
parents and teachers are facing and and
what they are finding value in front
from the seminars the webinars that's a
great it's a great question and we
definitely live in webinar mode nowadays
so thanks to everyone who's been joining
us over the last couple of weeks as we
move into this new sort of world order
that being said I think what we're
hearing especially from educators as
well as parents there's a hunger for
specificity okay we're now a month into
this thing and this seems to be the sort
of the way the world's gonna work at
least for the next several weeks how do
we make the most of this time how do we
serve our students and our children the
best way possible
and so what we've been hearing from
teachers is how do I do that at the
elementary level versus the high school
level how do I do that in my science
class versus my ela class and so for the
last several weeks we've been having
ambassadors share their specialty in
each of those different areas with
educators across the country and around
the world and next week is no different
and we want to make sure that whether
you serve students in special education
or English language learners you're
getting everything you need just serve
those students
sweet yeah and what advice may Megan ask
you first what advice do you have for
teachers who are you know they didn't
get a lot of notice that you know
they're now trying to figure out how to
transition their class and and and teach
virtually over Skype zoom whatever
Meghan what's what's your top tip or top
tips I think you're really hitting the
nail on the head cells that we're seeing
from a lot of teachers and parents and
I've shared students as well that
feeling of being overwhelmed a lot is
hitting everyone all at once and now
that we're thinking about this as being
more of a long-term situation I think
one thing that I would share right now
is that the focus immediately had been
how do I use technology with my students
but really to take a step back and think
about taking those classroom norms you
use in the brick and mortar classroom
and how you can transition that and use
your students as part of a community
building process of what are the norms
we want for our class what are the norms
are going to use when we use a video
conferencing tool like zoom or Google
Hangouts what are the things that we're
going to set is it classroom norms for
communicating with each other so
focusing on building that community with
your students and setting norms and
opportunities for communication first
and then using those tools like Khan
Academy to support those norms and best
practices as opposed to putting just the
technology first and Jeremy you know
taking the other side on the parents
side what advice would you have for
parents I think many of us are in this
boat I've felt it over the last couple
of weeks so if you're feeling
overwhelmed your kids are at home you're
trying to work from home if you have
young kids they make it difficult for
you to work from home at the same time
you have a list of to do's from their
school that you know you're trying to
take pictures of it and send it to their
teacher what what advice you have for
parents who are trying to navigate that
yeah all three of us are very much in
the same boat and there are millions of
other parents out there who are asking
themselves the same question right now
my own kids are causing up a storm over
in the next room so I appreciate their
indulgence that being said I would come
back to this idea from my early days as
a teacher in training which is about
getting quick wins so
I know that as a parent or as an
educator you want to come in and you
want to be a master of the situation an
awesome parent an incredible teacher but
it's tough to do when everything is
changing all around you and so what I've
been looking to do with my own kids is
find one moment in a day
when we have a really special moment of
connection maybe it's not transcendent
learning maybe it's not massive
educational games but just a moment we
have maybe a game of 20 questions or
would you rather do this or would you
rather do that around the dinner table
where we feel like a family in that
moment and not just the family in crisis
and so I think if you can just pull out
that one moment in a day really seize
upon that and be grateful for that
that becomes the building block for
routine and a family tradition you can
celebrate even beyond this crisis I
really like that you know one thing that
I've started obviously and this is
there's a certain irony coming for me or
from us but what I've really enjoyed is
I have one of those little tablet
whiteboards with a with a whiteboard
marker and I've just been writing a
problem of the day for my two youngest
my oldest who's 11 he kind of is doing
his thing and he's pretty productive and
my middle one is okay
but just writing that problem down and
we sit next to each other on the couch
it takes 10 minutes but I'm at least I'm
like okay they're doing something kind
of academic and then from there you get
that win and then you can start layering
on hey if we can do 20 minutes of Khan
Academy on the math side if we can just
read together or you know I'm a big fan
of these Bob books these early learner
reading things that I do with my
five-year-old that get you your wins and
then we published things like these
schedules that you can layer on over
time and actually to do for us I think
is to maybe you could be these schedules
show how you can use Khan Academy for a
fairly full school day including breaks
and lunch and all of that we don't
provide lunches but we can tell you when
they go and they could be but but I
think we also should we've been saying
it in these live streams and y'all have
been saying in our webinars but I think
even in our schedules we should probably
say hey even if you just do this part
you're a superhero and everything else
is gravy from every everyone else is
gravy from there and actually I've
gotten feedback lately that I say the
term everything is gravy and a lot of
people especially from other countries
are not familiar with it and so your
general idea is that mashed
chose by themselves are enough to
provide the calories you need but they
taste even better with gravy which you
don't necessarily need so anyway let's
see we have questions coming in from
also see so from there's a couple of
questions we could all take stabs at
some of these from YouTube yevette
janilla asks how do you help a kid that
struggles with testing either I want to
take a take of that I'm happy to jump
into Megan one taketh sure I'll take a
first stab at that and looking for it
seldom Jeremy two-tiered thoughts as
well is so I think for some students it
it's important to identify what it is
about the testing that might feel
daunting to them is it the content is it
the time boxed element is it just the
concept of that this individual that's
one thing I'm doing in this one moment
holds so much weight that that's
overwhelming for them so I think the
first step is is having a conversation
with your child or student and trying to
identify what it is that feels like a
struggle for them because sometimes even
that conversation takes off that first
level of what's so intimidating and then
if you can get into more the details of
is it the content is it the timepiece is
it the concept of an assessment that's
so troublesome once you know what that
is then there's opportunities resources
to kind of dig further into that and to
work with your child or student through
that particular situation yeah Jeremy
anything that to that yeah we just say
this is actually a chance for you to
really sort of focus on the most
important things in learning which are
mastering new skills not just trying to
get a test completed I think that's
actually a place where Khan Academy
shines I know with my own six-year-old
when she first started doing it she was
really frustrated because she was still
in that mental model of I have to get a
hundred percent and I have to do it in
the first go and then she realized that
she could actually take the same
assessment over and over and over again
with just her to wear off so she wasn't
focused exclusively on I need to you
know totally aces
the gates but instead build up that
muscle over time rep after rep practice
after practice until I get to that holy
grail of mastery and that's what really
matters and Khan Academy makes that
possible something that go ahead make it
I was gonna say and wonder if this is
where you are headed as well so I think
it brings a great opportunity Jeremy
what you're saying you say we have such
great growth mindset content on Khan
Academy and I think sometimes that
concept is so new to students and so
different from what they're used to in
some traditional classroom settings that
it's a great opportunity to even
leverage some of the growth mindset
content that we have from that we've
developed in collaboration with Hertz at
Stanford it's a great opportunity to use
some of that and work with your student
on building that growth mindset and
y'all are both talking about two
sometimes subtle things but I you know
things that we take very seriously here
at Khan Academy one is this notion of
mastery learning which is you know one
of the reasons why there's test taking
anxiety is you take a test you get a
seventy on it you're labeled a C or a D
student and that doesn't feel good while
all of us at Khan Academy we strongly
believe in this what mastery learning is
all about is that you got you took a
test you get a 70% on it not a big deal
what Jeremy was referring to is you can
then take a very similar test again and
you know I'm often sensitive when people
try to compare Khan Academy to other
resources and I look at some of these
resources and they'll just list like
five questions and I'm like no no you
don't realize we have thousands of
questions so that if someone doesn't do
get it the first time they can keep
taking it without seeing a repetition of
the same test or the same exercises and
obviously that we that takes a pile of
resources for us but we do it because we
so strongly believe that that first shot
shouldn't be your only shot and that you
should keep working until you can get to
70% 80% 90% maybe sometimes you can move
ahead if you need to but then you can go
back and remediate those gaps and what
Megan is referring to a growth mindset
which is very popular it's very in vogue
these days in education which is you
they have a fixed mindset where you say
I'm either good at this or I'm not or a
growth mindset where you say I only know
how good I am by applying myself pushing
myself out of my comfort zone being
willing to fail recognizing
failure is not a bad thing that that's
actually when I grow the most if I
reflect on that failure but a world
where you just give someone a test and
they get a 70 and then that's the end of
it you can't apply a growth mindset
there because then that's saying you are
70% student in order to actually have a
growth mindset you have to actually
really have mastery learning where you
get back up and you say okay I'm gonna
try this again that that's how it works
in other things if you're learning piano
and you mess up the piece people say
okay you're 70% go on in the next piece
they say keep working on it or in a
martial art or if you're shooting
free-throws you know the coach doesn't
say hey you're a bad free-throw shooter
let's move on to dribbling they say no
keep practicing cuz keep practicing
those those free throws so I think
that's huge and I'm making I like the
way that you break broke it down there's
a lot of things that could be happening
for a student who's having trouble with
testing I'll throw out another kind of
metal level thing which is just you know
meditation which sounds fancy and sounds
all new-age but it's literally and it's
it's literally just sitting down and
trying to quiet your thoughts and
realizing that you want your thoughts
and I think even for very young kids
that can oftentimes work because we can
get so overwhelmed because I think you
know especially when people say they're
bad test takers that's usually that
category that you talked about Megan
which is this notion of a test that
stret you know their brain starts having
circuits go that like oh my god oh my
god what if I can't answer this question
what if I can answer this question and
then it becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy so I think if you can kind of
step yourself step out of that that that
those cycling of thoughts which sitting
quietly everyday for for 2 minutes 3
minutes 5 minutes 20 minutes can really
help so there's a couple of questions
here this is a popular topic one is a
YouTube Leon Ann and YouTube Sixtus 106
Alaska both of them and please discuss
the transition for missions to masteries
world of math was unique in showing a
more unified view of the field can we
create a comparable view in the new
system and then Sixtus 106 asks hi Sal
why have you chosen to remove missions
from Khan Academy will you replace them
with something else well I'll take a
first stab which is for those of you
don't know my admissions it's the part
of Khan Academy historically and it's
still there today although people are
asking questions because we are what's
known in the software field you know
deprecating it which means over time
it's going to go away missions were a
way to get recommendations on what to do
next kids get practice feedback there's
all this game mechanics there are things
called mastery challenges to make sure
that you've mastered the concepts and
level up your mastery and the reason why
we are deprecating missions is there's
another experience on Khan Academy which
we internally we've called our library
view this is when a lot of you all have
done web searches you fell on Khan
Academy and then just like okay there's
there's a video there there's an
exercise there but what we want to do is
Khan Academy should feel like what a
good tutor would do it will help you if
you're cramming for that exam tomorrow
or you're trying to figure out how to
factor quadratics for your homework
tonight but what a good tutor would do
is hey we're there to help you right now
but you and I should keep working
together twenty minutes a day so that
you don't get into this stressful
situation again and historically
missions were where that happens but it
was kind of a different part of the site
and you had to click around to find it
and a couple of years ago we said well
what if we could merge the best of our
library view and our missions view and
that's what we are internally we call
course mastery on Khan Academy but now
when you go to what used to be the
library on Khan Academy you'll see that
it talked about mastery and mastery
points and it gives you these little
visuals that talk about your mastery
level and you can up level them by
working on a particular skill working on
quizzes unit tests mastery challenges we
just introduced a couple of months ago
course challenges and so we are trying
to bring everything that missions are
into the course mastery and it's already
getting quite close and so the plan is
before we fully deprecated or or sunset
missions we will have our core course
mastery do everything that missions do
and all the things that the library does
well which gives you more contacts it
makes it easier for you to jump around
understand why certain things are
connected to others when Leon asked
about the world of math that was a
mission where you essentially try and do
all of math on Khan Academy and I love
that notion I was obviously one of first
people who said hey there should just be
place where you learn everything because
it is all connected and so you know we
could I'm not sure if we have a course
but it would be nice to create a course
and our course mastered that's world of
math and that should get you where you
need to get go
so from YouTube Susanna Garcia Dominguez
asked when school starts again is it
going to be business as usual or will we
see changes what st. changes do you see
taking shape I'm love to hear you all
thoughts first Megan I think that
there's a couple things that again this
is all evolving right this is a whole
new world for all of us and I think some
things that we are expecting are you
know we see Summer Slide usually with
students and and sound Jeremy please
feel free to jump in here right we see
summer side for students now we're
looking at a world where students have
had even longer than that in the United
States especially to you know look at
that slide and try and fill in those
gaps from the year before and I think
Khan Academy has some opportunities for
teachers to leverage some of our you
know tools to be able to identify some
of those gaps for students to try and
get them back up to speed but we've seen
this longer gap between when students
left the classroom this spring and when
they hopefully are back in the classroom
this fall the other thing is we are
seeing that there's some possibility
that the school year for 20 20 21 could
be intermittent with times in and out of
the classroom and so I know there's a
lot of people all over the place trying
to work on pieces to best solve this
problem and I know that we at Khan
Academy are thinking about additional
ways and digital resources to support
parents teachers and students with
remote learning and teaching right now
of course but also how can we continue
that to make that transition especially
if it's intermittent how can we try and
make that more seamless and feel a
little more comfortable for everyone yep
Jeremy anything that of that yeah so I
think in addition to sort of the
challenges that this crisis has dealt
our entire education system there is at
least one silver lining that I've
identified which has so many of the
teachers have been coming to our
webinars are saying for the first time
in my whole career I'm finally getting
this technology stuff and as someone who
never talked about technology once in my
entire teacher training program I know
that it can often feel like this foreign
world that we're entering into but now
that we're getting these new skills just
like our students are always learning
new things we can bring new experiences
to our students and so I'm hopeful that
whenever school resumes
on business as usual it's gonna be
business as usual but better with new
technology new tools new resources to
serve students even more effectively
yeah and I'll just add to that you know
everything we've been talking about you
know the value of personalized learning
where your teacher with a classroom of
30 students who are all at different
levels all have different gaps you want
to do mastery learning but without the
aid of technology it's very hard to do
mastery learning you'd have to have
multiple tests that your administer to
teach students at different time and
somehow try to orchestrate kids on their
own path but the reason but but the need
for those things is even going to be
stronger to the point that Meghan just
made of kids are gonna be out of school
for five months six months our partners
at the nwea the not-for-profit that
administers the Mapp growth they just
released a study last week talking about
how those five months it's not just
going to be five months of lost learning
it's actually gonna be five months of
forgetting so it's very possible that
the median student if they don't get any
form of intervention they don't use Khan
Academy etc etc they they might enter
next year exactly where they were a year
ago so you would have a year of loss and
so it's super important that we leverage
this time not just the rent remaining
time in the school year but the summer
to keep learning and then when we go
back to school the reality is some kids
would have kept learning and other kids
for many reasons might not have kept
learning so they're gonna have even a
wider variation and so I think it's
going to be even more imperative
that's what Megan and Jeremy we're
talking about that when people come back
we hope that they can leverage us to
understand where their kids are and then
allow more time than normal you know if
I were to theorize I think we have
talked to some districts that are
thinking about starting the school year
a little bit early I think especially in
something like math although I think
reading as well but especially math
where once you have those gaps it can be
very debilitating to build on top of
them it might make sense for everybody
to have a double block or something for
for a month or two so they can really
remediate and catch up and if you do
have that type of time and that's where
resources like Khan Academy could be
really valuable like I could imagine a
month of you know really deep everyone
starts at you know we'd had Tim
Vandenberg on and I know Jeremy did a
web
with him as well amazing teacher in
history in California who has all of his
sixth graders start at kindergarten
level and Khan Academy if they know it
they're able to accelerate ahead if they
don't well they need that to fill in
those gaps and it but you know by within
a week or two they're all operating you
know closer and closer to their grade
level and I think there's concepts like
that that we could do you know
throughout the country or the world to
help make sure that everyone has their
gaps and if there's another silver
lining to what Jeremy at it is I think
this is the first time that people are
going to take summer seriously as a time
to learn and I think people are going to
realize that the variation is so large
this back-to-school that there that I
think more more school districts and
schools will say okay we've got to take
up this you know whatever this month to
get to reduce this variance to let
everyone fill in their gaps and that was
always an issue but the issue is so big
now that you can't ignore it so let's
see there is okay so there's a whole
class of questions here the youtubes
Nikhil go vendor asks are there
suggestions you have for teachers who
are teaching children remotely without
Wi-Fi then boy tjr asks the app is
amazing but if you don't have good Wi-Fi
or no Wi-Fi at all and then Zachary
Meadows is asking how could we help kids
without internet I'd love your all's
thoughts I'm what's got happy to happy
to give my my two cents Megan sure from
a taught Academy standpoint right a lot
of our system is is highly dependent on
consistent internet access and device
access which we know is a challenge for
many students all over the globe and so
there is one thing that I can and
recommend here is that our friends at
learning equality have developed a
system where if you have internet access
even for a small amount of time you can
download some of the aspects of Khan
Academy and use those offline so if your
students have access even to a limited
amount of Internet even for a small
window during the day or in a week you
can leverage that integration so that
students can still have access to
something like Khan Academy and I would
say even if they don't have internet
access one of the biggest things we keep
seeing for teachers and students and
parents is still finding a way to
contact your students and I saw this
really great post from a teacher this
week where
you wrote handwritten notes for each of
their students and even drop them off at
their homes which you know we don't even
think about you know snail mail anymore
for students and some of them don't even
think about that type of communication
well what a powerful impact that had on
her students to know that they as a
teacher she was still thinking about
them even if she couldn't see them face
to face every day so I would leverage
finding ways to communicate with your
students even if you can't see them
directly you know on a video call yeah
and I'll just add to that you know
there's there's teachers for teachers
who are teaching kids with a lot out
Wi-Fi I've seen teachers do things like
you know the students do their work
handwritten but at least use a parent's
phone to text them an image which is
reasonably common and Khan Academy is
usable on a cell phone so I know that
that's still there's still people who
might not have you know they might be
data sensitive or not have Wi-Fi access
but as long as a family member has a
cell phone that has the data plan a
smartphone they should be able to to use
us in in some way shape or form we are
hearing really good stuff coming you
know I've talked to dr. Jarrah from Las
Vegas from Clark County they've been
distributing laptops for kids who don't
have it I talked to Ray Dalio and his
wife Barbara in Connecticut they just
bought laptops their incredible
philanthropists who bought laptops for I
think 40 50 60 thousand high school
students in Connecticut so there are
programs out there and so I wouldn't be
surprised
obviously I don't know where everyone is
from but you know call your local cable
company I think they are leaning into it
now so I think they'd be inclined to
give you internet access at home or open
up other hotspots that might be in the
same building as you there might call
your school district there might be ways
to get access to devices I've seen
everyone's trying to do right by folks
right now so don't don't don't hesitate
to reach out I think you'll be surprised
how much help you you might be able to
get see other questions
so from Facebook Tasha right Knox asks
do pull kids that use Khan Academy to
see what they like and don't like about
the content structure etc and use info
to make changes so the simple answer is
yes kind of we do
put our stuff in front of students we do
see how it's like we do user research we
do that with teachers as well and we get
the data on what people are finding
engaging what changes to the site seem
to work what don't
and we run efficacy studies to
understand is it is it really improving
their their outcomes so the the from so
Nabil Amma the from YouTube says we are
not able to keep continuous
concentration on studies in isolation my
question is how can we overcome the
situation need a suggestion for Megan
all right Megan haha yeah focus is hard
and I would say student motivation and
even personal motivation is hard right
you I was a classroom teacher for nine
years and a big piece of my focus and
motivation definitely leveraged my
face-to-face time with students and
let's not neglect the fact that these
FaceTime with colleagues right that's
really helps you focus working as a
group or motivating students and so I
think one piece to think about is is
maybe as a teacher or a parent finding
opportunities to you know communicate
with your colleagues or friends finding
ways to be still social and share best
practices or shares ideas things that
are working right this is a challenge
for everyone and while it can feel
really isolating it doesn't have to be
as isolating still finding ways to work
in your as a teacher a peer learning
community or as a parent even finding
time to share like what might or might
not be working with your children I
think that's really important and when
it comes to student motivation I think
that's a big piece of helping them stay
focused and we're seeing some really
unique things coming from teachers and
Android necessity breeds innovation and
so we're seeing teachers you know find
ways of things around their house or
saying if you do this many of you
complete the assignment or you make this
much progress or as you know thinking
about our mastery system if you make it
to mastered in this skill I will you
know walk on Legos or grow up my
mustache or do a tick-tock video in my
you know children's Halloween costume so
we're finding really unique ways for
teachers to still motivate
students even when they're not face to
face so no great great great ideas and
unfortunately we have a lot of questions
continuing to come in and what will
happen again and Jeremy on in the future
but thanks for joining us both of you
and all the work you do on it on a daily
basis for you know helping teachers and
parents navigate all of this for all
y'all as I say every a live stream
thanks for joining if you're in a
position to do so please think about
donating to Khan Academy as I said we
were running at a deficit even before
this crisis and now our traffic is
roughly 2.5 3 X of what it typically is
so we definitely need your help and
support and you know keep the questions
coming keep the ideas coming because not
only do we need resources but we want to
make sure that how we deploy those
resources are most in service to helping
you the student the parent and the
teacher so stay safe and stay as healthy
as possible over this crisis and thanks
for joining it this is a fun way for all
of us to stay connected with each other
in this time of social distancing I'll
see you tomorrow
you